♪
>> Tammy: BIDEN'S DISASTROUS
GRIT AFGHANISTAN WAS ON DISPLAY
FOR THE WORLD TO SEE.
AND BOTH OUR ALLIES AND ENEMIES
WERE WATCHING.
WE TOOK ORDERS FROM THE TALIBAN,
HANDED OVER OUR MILITARY
EQUIPMENT, AND LOST 13 AMERICAN
LIVES.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION WAS
INCOMPETENT AND WEAK.
AND NORTH KOREA WAS NOTICING.
TURNS OUT THEY HAVE BEEN SOME
MILITARY WORK BEHIND THE SCENES.
ACCORDING TO A REPORT BY THE
UNITED NATIONS NUCLEAR WATCHDOG
AGENCY, NORTH KOREA HAS RESUMED
DEEPLY TROUBLING WORK ON ITS
NUCLEAR RACK TORE.
REACTOR.
LOOKS LIKE KIM JONG UN IS NO
LONGER LISTENING TO JOE BIDEN OR
IS LISTENING AND LIKES WHAT HE
HEARS.
JOINING ME NOW IS "NEW YORK
POST" COLUMNIST MIRANDA DEVINE.
I PUT OUT A TWEET WHEN ALL OF
THIS KIND OF EXPLODED NOTING
THAT AMERICANS SHOULD BEWARE AND
THERE WILL BE MORE TERRORISM AND
MORE VIOLENCE AND LOOK FOR
ADVENTURISM BY OUR ENEMIES.
THIS IS A PERFECT EXAMPLE.
WHAT IS YOUR TAKE ON THIS?
WHAT ARE THEY DOING?
>> ISN'T IT JUST, TAMMY, A
LITTLE TASTE OF WHAT'S TO COME
IN THE NEXT, YOU KNOW, THREE AND
A THIRD YEARS OF THE BIDEN
PRESIDENCY TO COME.
AND THE DEBACLE WITH THE
WITHDRAWAL FROM AFGHANISTAN HAS
JUST PUT UP IN NEON LIGHTS THE
WEAKNESS, THE FECKLESSNESS AND
THE INCOMPETENCE OF THIS
ADMINISTRATION AND HIS
ADMINISTRATION.
THERE ARE UNFORESEEN
CIRCUMSTANCES AROUND THE CORNER.
ALL WE KNOW IS THAT AMERICA'S
ENEMIES HAVE BEEN WAITING NOR
MOMENT OF WEAKNESS TO POUNCE.
THEY WILL IN EVERY WHICH WAY.
UNFORTUNATELY, YOU KNOW,
TONIGHT, WHAT SHOULD HAVE BEEN
A, YOU KNOW, A GOOD MOMENT OF
LEAVING AND ENDING THAT WAR IN
AFGHANISTAN WHICH MOST AMERICANS
WANTED WAS SO BOTCHED, IT'S DONE
MORE HARM THAN GOOD AND, YOU
KNOW, I CAN'T BELIEVE THAT JOE
BIDEN HAS LET TONY BLINKEN THE
SECRETARY OF STATE ADDRESS THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE INSTEAD OF THE
PRESIDENT DOING IT.
BUT WHEN HE DOES DO IT TOMORROW,
HE BETTER NOT TRY A VICTORY LAP
BECAUSE THIS HAS BEEN A DEBACLE
IN EVERY WAY AND, YOU KNOW, THE
MASSACRES FROM THE TALIBAN ARE
ONLY JUST BEGINNING.
THEY HAVE $85 BILLION WORTH OF
OUR SOPHISTICATED TECHNOLOGY AND
HELICOPTERS AND EQUIPMENT,
INCLUDING 7,000 OF THOSE
BIOMETRIC SCANNERS.
THEY HAVE ALREADY BEEN GOING
DOOR TO DOOR IN PURSUIT OF
COLLABORATORS WITH AMERICA.
THE TORMENT TO COME AND JOE
BIDEN TOLD US JUST TWO WEEKS --
LESS THAN TWO WEEKS AGO.
10 DAYS AGO IN THAT GEORGE
STEPHANOPOULOS INTERVIEW THAT HE
WOULD NOT BE LEAVING UNTIL HE
HAD EVERY AMERICAN.
HE DIDN'T DO THAT TONY OLYMPICEN
IS TRYING TO HOSE THAT DOWN AND
SAY THE UNITED NATIONS IS JUSTS
HAS JUST ISSUED A VERY STERNLY
WORDED RESOLUTION.
THAT'S JUST DELUSIONAL.
THIS IS NOT THE WAY ISLAMIST
FUNDAMENTALISTS WORK.
HE SHOULD KNOW THAT.
>> Tammy: IN LISTENING TO HIM,
IT WAS LIKE SOMEONE WHO HAD BEEN
LIVING IN A CAVE SOMEWHERE AND
HAD NO IDEA WHAT HAD TRANSPIRED
OVER THE LAST 30 YEARS WHEN IT
CAME TO TERRORISM.
IT'S VERY STRANGE ATTITUDE OF
CONTEMPT IN A WAY FOR THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
AND AT THE SAME TIME, YOU KNOW,
WE HAVE GOT THIS FRAMEWORK NOW
WITH AFGHANISTAN NOW WE'RE GOING
TO DO DIPLOMACY FROM QATAR AND
ALL OF THAT.
IT'S AS THOUGH THEY EXPECT TO
JUST KIND OF WALK AWAY FROM
THIS.
BUT THIS IS -- WE'RE LESS THAN
TWO WEEKS AWAY FROM THE
SEPTEMBER 11TH ANNIVERSARY AND
THEY DID THIS.
THIS IS THE IRONY OF WHAT YOU
NOTE ABOUT HOW HORRIBLE THIS
POSITION IS NOW.
THAT THIS WAS REALLY MEANT, I
CON TEND AND I THINK A FEW
OTHERS DO BECAUSE THEY WANTED A
PHOTO OP. FOR SEPTEMBER 11TH.
AND THIS IS WHAT RESULTED.
>> WELL THAT IS EXACTLY THE
WORDS THAT KATHY MACCALLUM USED
THE MOTHER OF 20-YEAR-OLD MARINE
RYLEE MCCOLLUM.
MY SON DIED SO YOU COULD HAVE
JOE BIDEN A SEPTEMBER 11TH PHOTO
OP.
IT'S HARD TO ESCAPE THAT
CONCLUSION BECAUSE THIS IS A
WHITE HOUSE THAT IS DRIVEN BY
OPTICS, NUMBER ONE AND THE
ENTIRE PREMISE OF THIS
WITHDRAWAL WAS NOT TO DO IT IN A
SAFE AND ORDERLY WAY.
IT WAS TO GET OUT, SO THAT HE
WOULD HAVE A BIG TROPHY BRANDISH
ON SEPTEMBER 11TH.
WE SHOULD NOT ALLOW HIM TO DO
IT.
>> Tammy: THAT'S RIGHT.
GREAT TAKE ON ALL OF THIS.
AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PERSPECTIVE.
YOU HAVE BEEN IN THE MIDST OF
EVERYTHING THAT'S BEEN HAPPENING
HERE IN NEW YORK AND IN T